been asked a lot over the years about
how to prep for a selection right and
there's mental and physical but the the
the foundation of everything that i
believe in when you're going through any
selection especially in the military is
is a 70-day course we'll look at ranger
school 70 days of being uncomfortable
hungry tired mad
guess what you gotta wear a ranger tab
for the rest
of your life sick and i never got
why people some people quit like halfway
three fourths of the way through ranger
school i'm sitting there going man
you're three weeks away from your life's
largest accomplishments something that
you can hang your hat on something
probably down the road when you have
children that when they when dad shows
their little son a ranger tab the the
inspiration that your child will go man
my dad did something hard and that's
what people have to do in this life and
so often especially with you know
technology and social media
all of our behavioral patterns are
becoming so impulsive immediate
gratification and
like put the [ __ ] phone down go feel
the grass like actually dedicate your
life with purpose to something and
follow through with it i mean i do weird
exercises every day like i
i tore my bicep about two years ago and
uh i took a while to rehab almost a year
and i said well i really took for
granted using both arms as silly as that
sounds so i bought a drum set and every
day i paid 20 i played 20 minutes of
drums and at first i could barely do
anything two years down the road you
know i feel like i could play a venue
and it's just weird tasks like that
where i challenge myself mentally and i
wish more people just
wrote it on their little pad it doesn't
have to be crazy like spanish is one of
them but i'm i'm a little lazy on that
one
it goes to show you think about it you
go through
three quarters of ranger school and
people still drop out that just goes to
show how smart the people that set up
the program are because it really does
take that extra effort to make it all
the way through or else everybody would
be trying to do it you know when we were
in dc you know i think one of the things
that this country lacks right now more
than anything especially unfortunately
young people is perspective we went to
the holocaust museum have you guys been
to it in dc yes
unbelievable right i mean how can you go
to the holocaust museum and then have a
complaint about anything in your life
you know i was listening to when jordan
peterson was on with you and he was
talking about new york city and talking
about what a minor miracle it is that
manhattan can exist
with 12 15 million people just the
infrastructure i was thinking the exact
same thing as i was walking the streets
of new york a couple weeks ago how does
this city even happen how does the
garbage get picked up how do the vendors
supply all the food in every single
restaurant and these people never miss a
beat how do the waiters show up how do
the windows get clean you know it's just
unbelievable if we could all take a deep
breath and not be offended by everything
you know we'd understand that what an
amazing existence life is and how lucky
we are everybody wants this vending
machine now and they think life is so
simple you know boom boom boom and you
get what you want but man after walking
out and dash was the one that really
wanted us to go to the holocaust museum
and i'm so glad we introduced you yeah
it was at the end of our trip too
you walk away from that you just need a
couple minutes it's just
unbelievable and they laid it out so
perfectly how they walk you through it
and you get the evolution and you see
how hitler it all started with
brainwashing people it all started with
a plan of four or five years we're going
to get you thinking a certain way and
then we slide in and do what our plan is
and chilling perspective is everything
and something i used to say quite often
was how do you have the
the unity and the patriotism of
september 12th without the tragedy of
september 11th
because you look at the effects of what
this country did it it reinvigorated the
american public to believe in itself
believe in the people right screw the
government it's america's awesome
because there's men and women willing to
give everything to protect it in the
name of freedom and liberty it's amazing
but we lose sight on that right because
we're convinced that you know you should
be offended at everything you do it's
just i don't i don't know the answer on
how to
because you have to go and seek
perspective
in these times because stuff is pretty
easy i mean we have inflation but
generally speaking america is a really
rad place to live like the best place to
live and
i don't know how we convince people to
have a better perspective to appreciate
that and and move forward just to like i
have one suggestion for people if you
want to have a better perspective in
life and if you want to relieve from
stress from your life you got to cut out
mainstream media if you're ingesting it
all day you've got to stop doing that
it's very harmful i mean even for
someone like me who's in the news right
and i've been in the media business my
whole life when i'm bombarded with with
this stuff you know the alerts on your
phone and whatnot and then you go and
like when adam went to new york when i
went to new york and you see it's not
that bad now unfortunately you know
calif i wish we could have shown you
some good parts and you were in orange
county orange county feels different too
doesn't it like a lot better night and
day so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here